I also spent a lot of time reading Carl
Young and it was through [inaudible] and
also John Piaget who was a developmental
psychologist that I started to
understand that are articulated systems
of thought are embedded in something
like a dream.
And that dream is informed in a
complex way by the way we act.
So you know,
we act out things we don't
understand all the time.
And if that wasn't the case,
then we wouldn't need a psychology or
a sociology and anthropology or any of
that because we would be completely
transparent to ourselves.
And we're clearly not.
So we're much more complicated
than we understand,
which means that the way that we behave
contains way more information than we
know.
And part of the dream that surrounds our
articulated know of his being extracted
as a consequence of us watching each
other and behave and telling stories about
it for thousands and thousands
and thousands of years.
Extracting out patterns of behavior
that characterize humanity and trying to
represent them,
pardon me,
through imitation,
but also through drama and mythology and
literature and art and all of that to
represent what we're like.
So that we can understand what we're like.
And that process of understanding
is what I see unfolding,
at least in part,
the biblical stories.
And it's,
it's halting and partial and
awkward and contradictory and,
and all of that,
which is one of the things
that makes the book so complex.
But I see in it the struggle
of humanity to arise,
to rise above its animal forebear say,
and to become conscious of
what it means to be human.
And that's a very difficult thing
because we don't know who we are,
what we are,
where we came from or any of those things.
And you know,
the light life is an unbroken chain going
back three and a half billion years.
It's an absolutely unbelievable thing.
Every single one of your
ancestors reproduce successfully
for three and a half
billion years.
It's absolutely unbelievable.
We rose out of the dirt and the Muck,
and here we are conscious,
but not knowing.